there appears to be
ethnic cleansing that's going on no one
has really given a flying Fig about what
on earth is happening inside kitchen
State they really believe that they're
going to end up being crushed and wiped
out unless they fight
[Music]
[Music]
we saw up close and personal what was
happening with the reinga the world's
attention has been so much focused on
their hunger they haven't noticed what's
happening elsewhere in the same country
the Myanmar military and the Myanmar
authorities have become almost
emboldened by what's happened and how
much they've got away with that they're
now turning their attention and their
guns onto another ethnic group this time
in the north and so we've decided it
would be a good idea to try and check
that out find out what was going on the
Burmese military has has sort of opted
is it's it's bombing campaign in the
Katyn State there appears to be this
ethnic cleansing that's going on in a
different part of the same country
though it's not on the same levels in
Kachin but the the indications of other
patterns are very similar but catch in
are a very strong rebel group with their
own hierarchy and their own army they
present a quite formidable opposition to
the miramar authorities it's like a
separate state within a state they
really believe that they're going to end
up being crushed and wiped out unless
they fight
[Music]
I mean to be honest I didn't have much
about kitchen or the kitchen people
before I started covering what was
happening in Myanmar
[Music]
most people don't know anything about
the kitchen people
they had lived in relative peace for
centuries
in the northern part of memmer
[Music]
[Music]
they've been fighting this war for
literally decades no one has really
given a flying Fig about what on earth
is going on inside kichan state
it's not been reported no journalist
allowed the Burmese government does not
allow journalists to go up north to the
13 area we decided we had to tell the
story the next step was to reach this
place
I don't want to go into too much detail
about how we got in because this will
expose the people who helped us
[Music]
but we were helped by a network of
people who managed to get us inside the
area known as kitchen State catching
catching catching
we didn't know what to expect we knew
there was fighting going on we didn't
know the lay of the land how far is the
fighting how close has the Burmese
military come to it is a very difficult
place to access that is for sure
moving around is quite difficult because
the Burmese military has advanced
certain places there are certain places
they have gone back when Britain gave me
amar their independence in the 1940s the
kitchen people were promised their
independence they were promised
self-determination promised equality
given all sorts of promises which never
ever happened
[Music]
the Myanmar military is actually bombing
these people they're bombing civilian
areas this bombing campaign has become
quite severe there's been thousands of
people who have been displaced bombing
from the air
villages or near villages trying to
force people to move and they have moved
in there tens of thousands terrified
people running being carried across
rivers on the backs of elephants just to
get a safety flared in terror and some
of the people that we spoke to had moved
or being forced to move multiple times
many of the families here have fled
attacks more than once jumping from Camp
to camp to try and find safety they live
right on top of each other no privacy
very little facilities very little all
together no aid agencies are able to get
there blocked by the Myanmar authorities
we spoke to one woman who'd moved I
think she said seven times
no no she spoke about the Myanmar
military bombing so close directed I
said they were terrified she won't spoil
a fight before young what they just ran
when they camped by the rivers they even
crossed the border into China and then
were sent back by the Chinese they're
trapped in that northern part of Myanmar
by the Chinese and the Indian orders so
they're really sitting sitting ducks
there
it's incredibly beautiful country
particularly that part because it's very
mountainous
it's very wild there's lots of jungle
but I think one of the reasons why the
kitchen have managed to keep older its
territory is limits like this
mountainous difficult a lot much of an
infrastructure the kitchen are a mostly
Christian group I noticed a lot of them
had red bandanas with religious writings
on the back of their scarf urging them
to go on and many of them appear to have
a very strong faith and belief that God
was on their side it's all jungle lands
all hilly or mountainous this trip was
pretty unusual on a number of levels not
least because we went in as a very small
unit and Neville and I were shooting all
our own footage a lot of the times in
very very challenging conditions the
humidity was something off the scale of
anything I've ever experienced
everything's just a little bit sweaty
nothing hot and it's really sweaty these
guys there's not a drop of sweat on them
it's very humid
I mean for ol Nevel
the camera was absolutely soaked it's
not something you want on Twitter and
such a journey what you're going to do
then probably we'll just keep it shut
down for the moment it revives and that
in itself was a challenge because we had
to cope with the physical exertion of
hiking with these guys who are very used
to the humidity in the conditions and
then on top of that the cameras
struggling to cope
there was always a lot of movement of
the Kachina independent army
they're regularly patrolling we were
continuously moving around with them and
we're tracking for almost 17 hours a day
and they did that at night as well we'd
be following the patrol and wondering
where on earth they were going and they
knew exactly where they were going they
obviously have been doing that on a very
very regular basis so whilst we were
slipping and sliding and trying to keep
up with them they were moving them
really stealthily looking through the
night vision and you can see things sort
of clearly you still can't really see
where you're walking or how you're
stepping and we spend most the time
falling they were using just their eyes
and I suppose your eyes get accustomed
but when you're switching between the
night vision and your normalised it's
like going from dark to bright the whole
time and your eyes can't let just show
off they would set up big camps within
half an hour they had everything worked
out and they would set up a kitchen cook
their food stay the night there we
stayed the night with them in the jungle
next morning they were ready to move to
another place
a lot of these outposts they're
literally within a few hundred meters of
a Myanmar or a Burmese outpost there are
only about 800 meters away positioned
right on the top that's where they mount
some of these attacks the soldiers from
either side are eyeballing themselves a
few hundred meters across different
hilltops they feel they're constantly in
their sights to different armies trying
to keep quite a high profile without
being too provocative they want to draw
fire because men on the ground with guns
cannot match a military that's got jets
and helicopters and lots of artillery
the problem is the Myanmar government
appears to have an agenda and they want
to get back control of the Kachin area
and at the moment the Quechan army is
standing in their way
is it a battle they can win I think it's
a battle they think they can't afford to
lose and they're prepared to do
absolutely everything to defend their
territory because their territory is all
they've got it's been pretty difficult
to get attention on this particular
issue because no one's interested it's
just another atrocity that's going on in
a little-known part of the world that no
one really cares about
[Music]
most of the public
I don't think know about it the problem
is the politicians do know and they're
still not doing anything about it
[Music]